الشعر هو يقوم على العاطفه في حد ذاته
العاطفه هو ايضا يعتمد على الجزء الاخر
اللي هو ما يسمى بالذكاء الحاد حتى تكون
شاعرا الان لو بعض الايقونات لا يمكن ان
تتكرر واذا كرت او حاول ان يكررها ستكون
اقل حضورا واقل فهما
لهذا الامر لو اخذنا مثلا شاعر ردت الفعل
موقفه انت تشاهد امامك موقف حركي الان لو
احد الشعراء جاب فوجد
صاحبه مصروبا فاخذ الموقف الاخر لما قال
علومهم في الحياه وفي المماتي مشهد تمثيري
امامك لحق تلك احد المعجزات نعم كانك واقف
خطيبه وكلهم
مددت يديك نحو احتفال كمدهما اليهم بلعباد
انت ان تقراه تشاهد مشهد تمثيلي امامك لا
يمكن ان تقدم بيتا وتؤخر سيختلف المعنى او
سيختلف هو عباره عن كل متكامل في هذا
الجانب اذا ذهبنا للمتنبي بما لا اهل ولا
وطن ولا نديم ولا كاس ولا سكن تعرف مباشره
حزين اريد حزن اريد من زمن اذا ان يبلغني
ملي سيبلغه من نفسه لا تلقى دهرك الا غير
مكترث ما دام يصحب فيه روحك البدن فما
يدين سرور ما سررت به ولا يرد عليك
الفائته الحزن مما اضر باهل العشق انهم
هوا وما اعرفوا الدنيا ايقونه لوحده لو
ذهبنا نزار قباني في مدخل الحمراء نعم في
مدخل الحمراء انت انت ان تقراها او تستمع
لها تفاعل تتفاعل مباشره في مدخل الحمراء
كان لقاؤنا ما اجمل اللواء بلا ميعاد عينا
لاحظ كيف الاسئله احيانا حتى الشعراء
القدامى او احيانا سؤال واجابه احيانا
حكمه في الموقف احيانا يعطيك ارتباط كل
متكامل يعني كانك تنظر في مشهد كامل في في
هذا الامر لو ذهبنا للشعراء حتى في النبط
نعم باللهجه العاميه تجد كل شاعر لايقونه
لا يمكن ان تتكرر لو اخذنا مثال مثلا بعض
غير وحول وحول ستكتشف مباشره ستختفي سيبقى
النص الاصل سيبقى الثابت ولن يتغير لو
حاول محاولات انا قرات ان هناك محاولات لم
تصل تجد فيها هذا السؤال في محاولات
لمحاكاه شعر النبطيه الان بالذكاء
الاصطناعي او حتى الشعر الفصيح اللي زي
النزار مر عليكم محاولات من هذا النوع
وجدت لكن لا ترتقي حتى يعني في من
الكسور لا
يصل حتى الكلمه اذا غيرت الكلمه فقط اخذت
النص وحولت بها هذا قد تصنع شعر للاطفال
بالذكاء الاصطناعي قد يعني تعلم لمن اراد
ان يكتشف ان الشعر لديه كسر او في اشكال
او كذا ربما يعطيك بديل لكن شعرا يستطيع
ان يصنع لا يستطيع ما يسمى بالسطر الاول
والخاتمه الان لديك بدايه ولديك خاتمه عرق
على ارق
وجوا يزيد عبره تترقرق جهد الصبابه ان
تكون كما ارى عين مشاهده لاحظ الان وقلب
يخفق ما لاح برق او ترى انما طائر الا
انتنيت ولي فؤاد يخفق جربت الى اخره لما
تقرا المتنبي وانت تبتسم حتى انهم يعني
الكثير اذا استمع الحكام
ومن يستمع للشعر تريد يبتسم تجده يطرب
الشعر في حد ذاته هو طرب لا يستطيع ان يصل
قد الذكاء ان يصنع انه يعتمد على العاطفه
اكثر يعتمد على اغلب الشعراء وهذه ربما
تكون اغلب الشعراء ليلا لانه يعتمد على
العاطفه ويعتمد على لا يعتمد على فقط قوه
العقل يعتمد على العاطفه ثم بعد ذلك يرمي
الى يعني في صنعه الشعر في صنعه اللي هي
الميزان ومن الميزان والبحور والى اخره
هذا الجانب صنعه منه بس الاساس هو فيه
الروح او المشاعر او الانفعالات كما فهمت
[موسيقى]
روح تجدها تتوافق معك